all right bobby yes sir bobby uh where'd
you grow up where are you from
originally i'm originally from montreal
canada i grew up in toronto
edmonton
saint catherine's
west west of canada
and i came to united states when i was
uh 11.
tell me about your family growing up
my family growing up was uh we're
gypsies
and uh i swallowed my first diamond when
i was seven years old
when my mother went to diamond exchange
she got dressed up my father got dressed
up walked me into the diamond exchange
switched the biggest diamond there was
stuck it down my mom gave me a glass of
water and told me to cross out which
means swallow
i suppose cops came searched us all
and of course they didn't find nothing
a half a day later i was [ __ ] it out
on a party
i should have a big diamond
we got 15 000 for it really yeah
that was my mom's car
tell me about your uh how would you
describe your childhood
my childhood
uh
i was around a lot of dope addicts
especially my father
he was taking pills up his downers
quailuds
my mother she would just smoke weed
until the time came she started popping
pills
and uh
they got out of hand
i went to the tv
got the bag of weight off the table
bought myself a joint went in the
backyard smokey got hot for the first
time i was nine years old
no
it got worse
friends were coming over my mother's
friends my father's friends
and i heard some noise in the closet in
the bedroom
and i got all my cousins and we're
around the table playing monopoly
actually
and i went to the door and i looked at
the keyhole and
my mother had her legs spread open
and she was getting laid by another man
and my father was right there
that was one of their biggest arguments
they couldn't live with each other after
that
my father
left my mother
got her back
and then my mother left my father
and she wouldn't come back she went to
hawaii to her family
and my father stayed in canada with his
family
then he got me up one day and he said
come on bobby
we're gonna take a trip
he took me to miami
took me to nasa
saw the first rocket that everyone in
space saw the whole castle by dream
genie
and uh
we have to plan with hawaii to my mother
got into a taxi and actually noticed any
gypsies
he took us right to my mother's house
it was amazing
and uh we stayed there three days
she wouldn't come back
she just couldn't take the beatings
anymore
he cried on her
everything
she wouldn't come back
so we left we came back to canada by the
time we came back to canada his father
was dead
my grandfather
steve butch
they made a very happy mountain prison
cemeteries
on the way back
my father stopped in mexico and bought a
gun
and punch up
as soon as we got back my grandma took
it from him put it away
he tricked my grandmother
and got it from
her right next door was a restaurant his
brother actually was in there
this man named bobby haynes used to come
over and talk about my father
my father was a lover a fighter
good looking man
six one
and uh he took my grandmother and took
the gun
all this time he was writing a diary we
didn't know about it
he put a cross at his head across on the
side of him on the right across on the
left and across his
feet he said goodbye mom
i walked out of the bedroom and i turned
around and came back in and i said
what'd you say and he already had the
gun to his head
and pull the trigger
he didn't mean to do it in front of me i
know i could look on his face
being we are gypsies we don't go to uh
therapy
psychologists and people like that
my grandmother said suck it up
life goes on
tell me about the gypsy lifestyle also
we pay for our wives number one you pay
for your wives we pay for our wives it's
a it's been our law since the beginning
of time
you pay the parents you've had parents
yeah
back in the day used to be take my 10
camels and my tall sheep and
now it's all about money
it's uh my wife gave me 15 500 to come
and ask for her i knew her and uh she's
a money maker
was con fortune telling
the girls i brought up with that fortune
telling
the guys i brought up for bodywork
fenders routine driveways
anyway to make a dollar
you know the girls
like i said fortune telling there's a
lot of contour there's a lot of truth to
it
you open up that book and say you got
bad luck well you got 40 50 000 to take
it away
they're gonna show it to you
my wife got my first money i ever got
was 180 000
cash
shiva santos
i sold her a car and was one template in
the dash and said palm and card reader
an advisor
takes away your bad luck
the ladies say her eyes got all glossy
and when he said who does this
i took it to my wife
my wife held in the dining room you got
a picture of the scene you surveyed
tablecloth
the candle lights are lit
the light is dim crystal ball on the
table
tarot cards are laid out
she told ladies to take an egg out of
her own fridge
and put a thousand dollars wrapped
around it and put in the under the bed
for three days and three nights
on the third day bring it back
my wife came to me and said i think i
put too much money on her bobby
she hasn't come back there was a knock
at the door
my wife stayed with her in the dining
room for two hours we got a peephole
because we get some crazy people
sometimes so i watch her
it's too late did you bring the bag the
egg she said yes
my wife took out the egg
with a thousand dollars wrapped around
took two thousand dollars out and burned
it on the candle actually burned it
there was no trick
it says you know in god we trust on
every bill
without
you need to feed your mouth you need to
put the roof over your head you need to
put the clothes on your back whatever
you're gonna steal you're gonna cheat
you're gonna manipulate
or you're gonna work from nine to five
it's the money it's the root of all
evil the lady gives her the egg while i
take the egg and breaks it out of the
egg comes a piece of raw meat
red
like one of our organs this is a piece
of the bad luck my wife says
you know what if you get a really bad
look you gotta light 180 candles
they're turning 10 karat gold and sicily
you gotta pay for the tickets round trip
and i leave my wife my husband and my
wife my kids
you gotta pay for those tickets too
she said okay no problem
it's ten thousand dollars a candle okay
no problem
four days later it was valentine's day
february 14th
so he knocked at the door my wife dumped
180 000 in my life
she said happy honor you [ __ ]
not gonna know that
my wife is what you call a hit and run
she don't keep my customers
unfortunately i did two years for that
they couldn't get a hold of my wife they
got a hold of me
she sent 21 000 to the moneygram and 21
000 from her bank to my bank she buys it
and uh because of that right there i did
two years and a half because i signed
for the money but what was illegal about
that
she said it was a car that there was no
bad luck and she tricked her so all
these fortune teller
stories are uh are mostly bs
most of them
that's like like i said earlier there's
a lot of true truth there's a lot of
faults to it it's like it's all the way
about like we're having a conversation
right now the way we're having the
accommodation i'm looking for tricks
that you're telling me right and i'm
going to use it against you clues yeah
clues exactly there's a lot of [ __ ]
to it a lot of books like i said if you
walk into my house in my store and show
me 50 60 000 tell me you got bad luck
i'm going to show it to you
right you know that piece of raw meat
that came out of the uh egg
was a piece of
meat from the fridge a steak
okay it was a piece of steak
and the hair that was around it was a
piece of my ponytail she to run i mean
like that and when she broke the age she
made it come on
so how'd you get to los angeles
i uh
well i jumped out the back window
in canada toronto
and i ran down the alley and i hopped
into the taxi and i went to the airport
to my mother
she was in hawaii at the time
and i went to her for the first time i
was 11 years old
on a plane by myself
prepaid
when i got to hawaii they picked me up i
stayed there until i was 22.
my grandmother had a heart attack
my father's mother
and they called me back
to her to canada when i got there she
was still holding on
for like three more days then she passed
she died in my arms
she was delusional she was calling my
father's name patsy
and uh
we buried her in toronto cemetery
not pleasant
that's what my father's buried my
grandmother my grandfather her
grandfather her grandmother lil berry
there
and my mother was in los angeles she
left hawaii in los angeles
and i came to l.a
and uh my wife was here
and i gave 55 for her married her
and then went to fiscal that's what we
made all our money
in san francisco
i bought some nice cars
about 280 clt mercedes
about 68 gt mustang convertible per
white with my pony interior all original
this guy wanted 20 500
from 30 500 i flipped a coin i'll get it
for 10.
he had my daughter the coin and my
daughter crystal calls it
tails i got the car for 10-5
i have two weeks they stole it
that's in san francisco
had some nice houses some nice stores
right here at a store in third in
fairfax it was a yoga place
and i positioned it off
i held that store for almost three
months
my wife had another score for 55 000.
take away somebody's bad luck
i moved five blocks away
she had another school we had a house
she had another score for 35 000.
like i said she's a hit and run
she don't keep her customers which is
very easy
when they're running again i've been on
the run most of my life
my real name is bobby butch wallace
my mother's name is butch my father's
name is wallace
here i'm scott peter adams
how do you support yourself now
i have gr
and i boost
i boost ridiculously every day
i mean every day to eat to drink
what's your technique for stealing from
stores uh my technique is returning
i'll walk into the store i won't even
walk out
i'll pick up merchandise whatever it is
nice 3400 jacket she's one of her shoes
and go right to the counter and return
it
so i lost the receipt my wife bought me
this it's not the right size
or it's just unfit
and usually if you ain't got id
then they'll give you a gift card
and or they'll put in the bag and tell
you to come back and then i'll take you
to somebody else and sell it
usually when you got id they'll give you
a gift card
i had a gift card one time for two
cappuccino makers you had to make me two
gift cards
for seven hundred fifty dollars a piece
that's the biggest i ever got for
eighteen hundred
so a lot of the a lot of your life has
been
it's been
muscles manipulating stealing
cons con a lot of a lot of my friends
i pushed away from me because every time
i get close to somebody
they need to rob me
it's been a long time since i've uh put
something on the counter and wake up the
next day and it's still there
it's been a long time
i was at the mayfair hotel for almost a
year and a half
just
two months ago
and my boy josh archer did 15 months and
got out and came to me
he said gypsy i need to take a shower
get cleaned up it's my boy for a long
time i couldn't refuse him
i told him to uh keep your head down
walk in the hotel and give somebody's
room number
and get on the elevator and come to the
eighth floor and go to my room 306.
he did it
he made it through security came on my
floor came right to my room i let him in
he was doing fentanyl
so am i
and uh
he hasn't done it in a while but he's
been with the cartel he's been here and
there and he's used to it only now when
he takes a hit
he beats himself up
he scratches his face he scratches his
body makes blood
breaks the room he doesn't come back to
himself for like three hours looks at me
says gypsy what did i do
bro you just broke my lamp you just look
at your face look at your stomach
and this is every time he would take a
hit
so he tried to his mother just sent him
17 000 from his dtv money
and uh he had 1700 on them
as i was leaving my boy billy and rocket
came over
stole them half a gram
and uh
i went to work at 9 30 in the morning
came back 10 30 at night
he locked the door from the inside i had
to get secured open the door
i went in and he was dead on the floor
legs crossed in a indian position
hands crossed dinner beside him
so he received the dinner at six
worth five
and maybe died at six
he died
fennel and xanax
that's why when people around me do
xanax i don't want to be part of it
do you have children i have two girls
beautiful girls crystal and gina
uh
we all got separated when they was nine
and ten they're your part
they're unseparable bro
they live in the same house in san
francisco
they moved to vegas
and she goes upstairs my daughter
crystal my daughter gino is downstairs
they're fortunate tellers
my daughter gina
she could take a carburetor apart
and put it back together blindfolded i
told her that
and my daughter crystal is just like her
mother
straight fortune teller
uh they're both married they're both in
the same house
they made me a grandfather
rosianna santino my daughter crystal
michael and angela my daughter gina
and they're uh 31 30 now
and uh my daughter crystal's 31
she's got sugar diabetes
she's dead she takes three shots today
she's been doing that for the past eight
years
my ex-wife
jumped out of a frying pan to a fire
she left me and married this guy called
the bimbu
that's a clan
it's the lowest lowest i'm not just
saying it's the lowest clan you can get
for gypsies
they see [ __ ] in the corner
they won't pay somebody to take it out
they'll just leave it there
he's a crack addict
he would steal her money going alley
and get high
figure out her purse
and she left him finally she's on her
own
the kids tried to get us back together
and they took me for my birthday three
years ago to vegas
and uh
she finally came
no chances
i couldn't see sitting at the table with
her
she cheated on me twice i never cheated
on her
with other gypsies
i was always faithful
and then when we separated
i got married again
about four years later i met a girl
named lina from montreal another gypsy
girl
she turned out to be
a crag addict speed adding
any kind of drug there was a farmer she
would do are there a lot of drugs in the
gypsy
culture a lot of drugs
well no you know what i'll take that
back
in my lifestyle yeah other gypsies
no
no i stepped out of the gypsy community
because of my sisters
my mom passed away
and when she passed away everything just
went to [ __ ] everybody went on their own
my two sisters susie and sabrina
my sister sabrina i blame for my
marriage
because she was cheating on her husband
and taking my wife on her dates
and the guy she was cheating with was
bringing his brother
it was just a matter of time before they
clicked
they clicked
she tricked me
from san francisco to l.a
to vegas
put all my stuff in the storage your
storage
and i didn't have a lock
so it was that much
off the ground
so we can come back into the next day
well i went back there four days later
my wife already left
she ran away you don't know who yet
and i went and i opened up the storage
and uh everything's gone they robbed me
and uh
actually two years later my wife called
me and said you know what this
[ __ ] beat the [ __ ] out of me cut
my hair
their lifestyle the biblio when
like i got used to my wife going to a
club
and coming back look like she just got
[ __ ] and sucked and i was winning all
the way through but she didn't
he didn't he wasn't used to that so when
she came back that night when she went
with all the girls and she came back
that night
it looked like she got plugged in so he
beat the [ __ ] out of her cut her hair
and put it in her closet
for two days
she finally got out
got the phone called me and told me that
i went with my boys 18th street
and i went down there in a van
went to the house that she gave me
walked right in he was nowhere in sight
went upstairs downstairs looked all over
the backyard front yard
over the side took my kids put him in
the van
took her two big boxes put him in the
van
and i left
i uh
it's in the newspapers
i blew up the house
but they don't know that it was me
i left the gas on fire i left the candle
i left the gas on the stoves left the
camera before i walked out
finally seen a picture of him on the
driver's license never knew what he
looked like
and uh
i was maybe
not even half a mile away
we heard the boom
the hospital
yeah i know where to live no more
and uh i had my wife for uh
three months
the son of a [ __ ] got a hold of me
called me and said do you play chess
bobby
i said what the [ __ ] you talking about
who the [ __ ] is this this is ronnie the
one who run away with your wife
so what the [ __ ] you waiting was you
play chess i say yeah [ __ ] he
goes don't curse me i'm not cursing you
check and you hang up
i dropped my wife out to the beauty
parlor
and he picked her up
she called him and he picked her up
and uh
she ran away with him again
only this time i had my daughter gina
she had my little
crystal my kids their hearts were
brokenhearted
for almost a half a year
she called me up again like a dumbass i
took her back
i took it back the first time because i
was still in love with her
second time i tried to make it a go
third time
i got married
i gotta meet somebody else no gypsy girl
and she has the balls to call me and say
why did you get married what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you i said what'd you say
what's wrong with you
she wasn't she was all there for making
money
but for being a normal person
she wasn't all there
he said her grandmother was a little
quicker too
she takes off that side
uh by the gypsy levels buying selling
cars
i was doing that left and right i
learned from my uncles
michael stevie my uncle frankie
uh credit card scams
we did a nice look in hawaii
over 500 000.
over there
you can order a rolex over the phone
that relax you got in the window i want
to have a gift wrap i'm on the golf
course i'm going to send somebody over
there to pick it up
i can't make it in time
and they will wrap it up and now we go
over there and pick it up
you have packages from soso yes we do
man get your credit card over the phone
we ran out of stuff to get my mother had
long diamond me cold my sisters shoved
me coats
rolex watches
men's women's ray-ban glasses you name
it we got it
at the end i went for uh
a pair of binoculars and a tv
michael stevie told me to go pick it up
i told him i just came from there i
picked up regular glasses don't worry
about it just go
i went there on the second floor i asked
for the tv
two simones came from the back
grabbed me threw me on the counter
take us
and uh
they wanted 15 000 cash bond on me
my uncle came to bail me out they had
him on camera
ten thousand dollar bond for him
the detectives wouldn't put a cash bond
on us no more they said there is no bond
it was lunch time
they walked out for some reason my
mother was right there she put 25 000
cash
made my uncle walked out of that cell
hopped in the car went to the airport
hopped on a plane and left away
literally that's hawaii i look like i
didn't say goodbye to my girlfriend to
nobody
and uh
we went to fiscal
seven years later i was in l.a
they kicked open my door get on the
ground
and behind my back
at the same time they keep opening the
door to fiscal my uncle stephen
they got him too he knows uh he's good
friends with shapiro
very good friends
they used to have dinner together lunch
and he called him
and shapiro did over the phone
dropped my case natural limitation seven
years
and my uncle's case seven years and uh
he dropped them dropped them both the
only problem is when i go to vegas i get
pulled over every time
they run me and
honolulu hawaii pops up wanted stop
peter adams
and
they hold me in their cell in vegas
for about two hours they call hawaii and
hawaii tells him calls him right back
and says we don't want him
every time two hours later
let me go right in there
give my property and leave
that goes until today
i guess then i'm taking a computer
if i go there i'll get locked up
they won't hold me
because of such limitations
what what regrets do you have in your
life you guys do i have yeah
my father
for him putting the gun to his head
shooting himself that wasn't your father
i could have stopped it i think
i could have went to him told him how
much i love him
i knew he got the gun from my
grandmother
he treated us all and said he was going
to sell it to somebody
he wanted to get out of the house
but the guy named bobby hayes would come
over my grandfather's brother and talk
about my father how he's no good he's a
dope addict
he was married twice we used to beat up
my mother you see up the other girl
my father couldn't take it anymore
hearing all this [ __ ]
the only one that loved him was my
grandmother
he thought
so that's that's my regret my father put
the gun to his head
he shot himself
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
the most important lesson i learned in
my life
i stayed away from pills
because of my father
it was easy very easy for me to do it up
as downers
i've tried everything one time
everything pcp different hair and
bombing fluid
everything
and
the only thing that got a hold of me
was heroin
i did that for like almost 10 years
it was cracked
then it was her on i quit the crack went
to speed
quit the speed went the hair on went
back on speed
and that was fentanyl
uh matter of fact i just did a diamond
heroine last night
i split it with somebody
and
it didn't do nothing to me
nothing
makes it a little speed
he didn't do [ __ ] to me
i couldn't wait to get ahead of fentanyl
i'm almost shaking right now because i'm
getting sick
and it's crazy because
i take a hit
it just it takes the sickness away
that's it there's no more high
it's just about getting well
you know
so
stop the pills i'm glad i did that
i lost my wife because
our friends got too close
which happened to my father
my biggest regret is my daughters
i was there for them at a certain time
everything they had they seen they got
my doors were wearing tennis bracelets
eight thousand dollar tennis places on
their legs
because we had the money
everything they would see i would get if
they didn't get it then i'd get it the
next day
and uh my wife he didn't like me there
it wasn't 180 it was 280.
we brought our family in round trip
tickets
i gave my mother 20 000 under the table
my mom said this must be my lucky day i
said why your wife was just here 20
minutes ago she did the same thing
here before he gave her twenty thousand
i was totally forty thousand my mother
got
and we still had money i went to the
state deposit box and i still had all my
envelopes and i bought cars ridiculous
i bought her a cadillac to stay away
from my cars
she was a manipulator
stores
big manipulator
but like i said
she's a good fortune teller when it
comes to con
when it comes to making money
me i do my body and fender work
roofing driveways and even there
it's the car because i'll knock on
somebody's door
somebody do roof in the driveway and
i'll try and get the job for driving but
i want to go up in their house and we
look for the walk-in safes
and usually we find them we usually
smell money mile away
all gypsies do
when they've got curtains in their house
and their windows that's money
old life shades that's money
uh the garden in the front that's money
these are people that like to stay home
they don't go and get the munition
blinds when you hit the button and they
open up
or the new livestreams that don't need
lime change
and uh
i was i i was going to write a book like
three four times
called short stories by gypsy
and uh i heard about you
i heard about you from a few people
and i've seen uh
a few of your videos
and a few people that you've done
like michelle
for one
never went out with her
good friend of mine
miami is a good friend of mine
they always stole from me
just now she stole from me
and uh
i just got section eight
i just got it matter of fact i got a
call
this afternoon and find out what's going
on after i see my voucher on computer
it's eighteen eighty a month
and i gotta start looking for a place
she took all my paperwork my watches my
jury
i stayed with them in the tent
and uh she swears up and down it wasn't
her
it hadn't been miami
and i don't understand that either
because i just put 20 dollars in his
pocket we went to booths together
and he had all the merch
merchandise and i put 20 dollars in the
pocket bottom pack of cigarettes got the
fentanyl split it with him
but we tried to make it back to the tent
before the girl gets there because i
called her a [ __ ] i argued with her
and when you call her that she takes
your stuff and goes and sells it
it's her habit
so he tried to make it back and it was a
half a block away my bag gave out
i couldn't make it in time he said all
right i'll go ahead of you he went ahead
of me
when i got there
he wasn't there the chip was tipped over
the blanket was over and all my [ __ ] was
gone
i seen him two days later
he says the tip was burnt down to the
ground
no such truths
i burnt the tent down when i got there i
looked all over my stuff i couldn't find
the only thing i could do i broke your
tent down that was my revenge
do you regret living a gypsy life
when i stepped out of the gypsy
community yeah
when i was in the gypsy community
no
i loved the lifestyle
we lived in lifestyles originally famous
only being rich and famous
but
that ten thousand fifty thousand sixty
thousand eighty thousand
we buy our cars get our clothes go to
clubs
eating go to other people's houses
that's what gypsies do you go to
people's houses they eat they drink they
have a good time
people get guitars together start
singing
old school
now
i'm not there no more
i stepped out
and i became the white man's life you
should say
and now it's just straight little drugs
boosting
it's very easy to me to go get a store
and
get her two thousand three thousand paid
a rent and tell them that not to charge
me to wait for another three months
because i gotta fix it when i'm going up
and down out of state so it's gonna be a
while
but meanwhile i'll be living in the back
fix up the front fortune town buying
sell cars
i could have done that ten thousand
times
the drugs just got me
i don't like it lazy
don't wanna do nothing
but i wanna get up and go boost
to make the drugs again
it's crazy
all right bobby thank you so much for
sharing your story
thank you
wish you the best of luck thank you very
much
you